[Music]
what's happening flavor here with a
little baby you never met before this
guy's name is super bad I've had him
since day one it was him and a Siamese
named DJ and two little chubby girls
named Lou levy right but the two guys
were living outside look at this guy I
was like I don't know about him but his
brother got sick and he got sick so we
brought him upstairs and one night I got
some powder came home [ __ ] up and the
one was really sick upstairs a Siamese
when they died so I had this one left I
don't like this guy too much I called
him super bad and my wife came in and
said DJ died so I went in got my hands
and knees and I said I'll never do
Coakley kind of dislocate eyes you know
if he lives I'll never do drugs again
that was four years ago look these men
those who they're near this guy he's not
no Beauty [ __ ] King he's no you know
he's a little tough [ __ ] I love them
with all my heart there you go you been
super bad on the season finale of mad
flavors world it's so bad what's
happening beautiful people that flavor
Joey Diaz in front of Bob Oh Medical
Center
I'm here because let me tell you the
story whenever I go swimming and I don't
take off my little [ __ ] bikini or
whatever I wear I get a sudden rash in
my [ __ ] nut sack it's just a debt I
gotta get the SPECIAL cream because the
moisture just [ __ ] kills me I went to
the beach a couple weeks ago and I
didn't switch I said the Beach Boys ride
off a little bit but I got the itch
again I was gone for five days so I'm -
scratching like a [ __ ] like I like a
Viking victim try a little doctor get a
supreme that's it that's why I'm here
check my blood pressure with the shirt
I recently
but now when a yarmulke smoking a number
who's better than him and who's better
than me and who's better than you it's a
beautiful day to be alive here in Los
Angeles I'm gonna go in there let's see
if I'll let me bring the Cameron all
right waiting for dr. Weiss to come I
got good news today after the New York
trip eat Chinese food hi world's my
blood pressures 130 over 80
that's not bad especially this morning
after I smoked a few numbers I had a
pretty good breakfast of bacon one egg
and a piece of toast so 130 over 80
something's going on that's not bad I'm
saying but I pay everything up the scan
they have this stuff to put you here I
didn't wake myself I went myself
yesterday Weight Watchers Ella came to
pound in New York for days gonna only
gain the pound was better than me
my man muffins except my wife like that
math flavor let me tell you I go to
Starbucks people want a coffee bean all
this stuff to hang out the misery the
best coffee is ready seven [ __ ]
eleven they got a Brazilian bowl
that'll keep you a bounce in four days
understand me forget my wife she's
getting ready to step for pool in the
morning
me I got a half a cookie man to coffee
to balance me out and that's how the
real pimps do you know saying where's
muscles at
where's my man muscles give me a pose
for the camera that put you on TV there
give me give me a pose that can give me
a something show BAM there he is that's
looking a BAM that's my boy we still
good
YMCA together they said [ __ ] I'm
gonna go Jim
look at me joke bounce that's the real
deal man flavors world stay away for
your [ __ ] hot dogs don't kill you
just get the coughing and I'm saying mad
flavor here showing you the
international flavor that I give you
investigative reporting look we're at
the Medical Marijuana doctor 500 six one
nine nine nine Gollum come on down to an
anxiety card give him 60 [ __ ] disease
and there you have it medical mile one
that's how easy this guy's
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about that
mufflers [ __ ] baguette
shake that thing for uncle Joey come on
I'll show you a ball lift it up show me
the [ __ ] muffler she's looking at me
like she don't know what I'm talking let
that [ __ ] dinner come on come on what
the [ __ ] you went out you little [ __ ]
filthy animal on a [ __ ] bike in
Colorado this one joggling my people you
never know what the [ __ ] you gonna bump
into the things you see when you ain't
got a gun you know st. look at this
[ __ ] outlet he hasn't calmed his hand
through from completely he has the nerve
to leave the [ __ ] houses we'll talk
about people this guy he looks like
[ __ ] sup look at his head look I
think Lou Lou he's just sitting in you
know this astma smell like this I'm
talking about mad flavor where I'm just
picking up the flaws of life
I got mayhem on the other side when Ari
Shaffir
laughs Labor's on this side or I look at
this [ __ ] lace here
Denver [ __ ]
and Grable
Jr these crazy [ __ ] I love them
eating like an animal here with the men
Joe Rogan Ari Shaffir mayhem Miller and
of the merry man I Fogo de Chao look at
this place there yeah this is nothing
but meat potatoes or is water like
doctors looking mayhem never hold up
that thing like a cat's leg you
understand me that's how we do it at
Matt flavors world forget Weight
Watchers we're folk with a child talent
good this is how you're supposed to eat
this is how man was designed to eat meat
and vegetables this is this is the most
satisfying meal I won't stay black stay
back
Matt flavor here with his favorite
[ __ ] Englishman whatever I got born
since [ __ ] Ozzy has won this thing I
took over cause y'all's gonna ain't got
[ __ ] on me that's how we do it man
flavors yeah I am British I got the
[ __ ] video blogs grunting Sam get
your nice if anybody jobs but [ __ ] guy
knows what he's talking about he's
knocking that [ __ ] out your [ __ ]
other people out here at the st. Olaf
thank you brother Michael Bisping
English bad [ __ ] I love him stay
black [ __ ]
rich and dragging it the Chinese
restaurant I talk about all the time the
world's grins Chinese wrestle in
California
I go coast to coast and this one hands
down has always gotten me understand me
we walk in here in the old days I come
here get a zombie in a pattern is very
good my dad come on I've been coming
here since 1979 they used to drive up
here from the high school to teach you
to drive us up we used to get steak on a
stick and whatnot I guess last year I
had last time I seen this young man it's
got to be much one fighting he was eight
seven yeah [ __ ] dreams like my eye of
rose meaning he lives like I stand here
I was a good man stepper nice taking the
[ __ ]
disappeared
[Music]
I love you
bayonet season
[Music]